commission and Council
decoration on
keeping energy bills low
and the introduction of a windfall tax
in the context of the war in Ukraine now
on behalf of the council allow me to
give the flood Ivan Bartosh
foreign
honorable members commissioner Mr Vice
President of the European Commission
we welcome the parliament's initiative
to keep this issue high on the agenda
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine and the weaponization of energy
supplies have driven Energy prices to an
unprecedented level and created a very
difficult situation for many households
and companies
Russia's aim is clear hit our societies
and our economies to create internal
descent and to fracture social cohesion
we will not let this happen
the EU is collectively doing all in its
power to address various dimensions of
the crisis and in particular to mitigate
the effect of rising prices I will
address the main dimensions of this
coordinated response
a the energy Supply
first we are taking all possible
measures to avoid energy shortages this
winter
in only a few months we have Diversified
our supplies replenished our storage
facilities
close to their maximum ensured safety of
supply and taken steps whenever possible
to encourage the economy to consume less
we see that the price increases way more
heavily on low-income families whose
energy needs account for a higher
percentage of their budget without
government support many cannot afford
that
the explosion of energy prices is also
hitting hard smes and an energy
intensive companies many are facing an
explosion of their costs many risk going
bankrupt some production has been
discontinued some companies have closed
down others have no alternative but to
move their production outside Europe we
must stop that
in order to address these challenges
energy ministers at the end of September
reach an agreement on allowing to offer
regulated electricity prices also to
small and medium-sized Enterprises not
only households and micro Enterprises
demand reduction measures including
voluntary overall reduction Target of 10
percent of gross electricity consumption
and reduction Target of five percent of
the electricity consumption in peak
hours
capping Market revenues obtained by
power generators using low cost
Technologies other than gas
mandatory temporary solidarity
contribution applying to the profits of
businesses active in the oil gas coal
and Refinery sectors which has
significantly increased compared to
Prior years
the second Dimensions or the B if you
like fiscal measures
at the national level member states are
doing their part and have taken over the
past few months numerous fiscal measures
to alleviate costs for businesses and
Families
these include lower indirect taxes
social transfers to households direct
interventions on prices paid by
consumers and extraordinary taxes on
windfall profits on which I speak later
we need to make sure that these measures
are temporary and well targeted so that
they make a general difference for the
most affected parts of our society our
fiscal resources are not unlimited let's
use them efficiently
the third dimension social measures
uh on the social front the Czech
presidency decided to dedicate the
informal meeting of employment and
social ministers few days ago on 13th
and 14th October uh to discussion on the
impact of energy poverty and Ukrainian
crisis in this context I'm pleased to
mention that the recent adoption of
minimum wage directive which is powerful
and very concrete signal of the
importance of the EU attaches to
ensuring a decent standard of living of
all workers
it is only the over combined efforts
that we can raise to this Challenge and
I look forward to an efficient
cooperation with you on all the
proposals and initiatives we work
together on
and finally the fourth dimension
windfall profits let me turn down to
issue that that matter of the wind for
profits on the 7th of October a new
regulation on emergency measures to
reduce energy prices entered into Force
the regulation introduces measures to
collect and redistribute the energy
sector's Surplus revenues to households
and small and medium-sized Enterprises
more particularly the new regulation
addressed two types of windfall profits
first it limits revenues of the
electricity generators including
intermediaries that use so-called info
marginal Technologies to produce
electricity such as Renewables nuclear
and lignite this is done via the
introduction of a cap on the market
revenues on of uh infra marginal
Technologies at 180 Euros for megawatt
hour member states will be able to
redirect the Surplus revenues generated
via the introduction of such kept
towards supporting and protecting final
electricity consumers
secondly the regulation introduces a
mandatory temporary solidarity
contribution on the profits of
businesses active in the crude petroleum
natural gas call and Refinery sectors
the solidarity contribution will be
calculated on taxable profits as
determined under national tax rules in
the fiscal year standing in 2022 and all
in 2023 the solidarity contribution will
apply in addition to regular taxes and
Levis publicable in the member states
this regulation was adopted in less than
two weeks as an emergency solution to
current crisis uh what I presented here
today was an overview of what we as the
EU managed to achieve in only a few
months to ensure that families and
companies are shouted from the worst
Economic Consequences of this
unjustified war of aggression we do not
know what the future holds or how long
the current conflict will last but we
will certainly maintain our resolve to
see Collective and articulated responses
to ensure a sustainable cost of living
for our citizens thank you very much for
your attention
at sleeping tank
thank you very much indeed Mr Bartos
now I welcome vice president
and Mr gentilloni on behalf of the
European Commission
and I give the floor to
vice president of Graphics to begin
uh honorable chair honorable Minister
honorable members of the European
Parliament
uh Russia's illegal aggression against
Ukraine is causing a social economic
upheaval across Europe and Beyond
uh families and businesses face surge in
food and energy prices they are deep
financial and monetary implications too
lower income households are worth a hit
as they spend proportionally much more
on food and energy
businesses are also affected by Rising
energy costs higher financing costs and
lower consumer confidence
the current shock is very different from
the covid-19 pandemic so our policies
must be a different too
uh there are three questions to ask at
the moment how to minimize the costs
caused by this war how to distribute
those costs fairly and how to lay ground
for future Prosperity I will address
each one in turn
first we need to work on the root causes
of inflation in the energy markets
this requires action to secure
alternative sources of Supply to reduce
our energy demand and to address the
current situation in electricity and gas
markets
the European Union has set up a platform
for joint purchase of gas and we are
increasing gas imports from the reliable
suppliers like Norway and United States
member states have agreed energy
consumption reduction targets and
exceptional measures while we prepare a
broader review of the functioning of the
electricity markets
the commission will present this
afternoon additional measures to address
gas prices and guarantee the security of
supply for next winter
and we're also mobilizing additional
Financial Resources for member states to
introduce the power EU chapters in their
recovery and resilience plans
honorable members the more successful we
are regarding energy the stronger
economic and social position will be in
second we must protect vulnerable
households and businesses
it will not be possible to Shield
everyone from The Economic Consequences
of the war however the public sector
must protect those most exposed to high
energy and food prices
uh above all this means providing Income
Support to those whose purchasing power
is most under threat and to worst
affected businesses
to achieve that our support must be
targeted temporary and retained
incentives to reduce energy consumption
as a price couple Market revenues for
infra marginal producers and the
solidarity level for the fossil fuel
sector will allow member state to
channel these revenues from very large
profits gained through unexpected
circumstances towards those who need
support the most
uh to provide generalized fiscal support
uh would be not very helpful
uh it would uh fuel inflation uh bring
even higher energy prices and
potentially further weaken as the
economy
uh the European Central Bank is doing
its job to contain inflation the EU and
the member states need to do their job
as well
fiscal policy and monetary policy should
not work at Cross purposes this means
providing effective support measures
that are well targeted and compatible
with prudent fiscal policies that do not
add to price pressures
uh honorable members we also must look
Beyond this crisis so lastly we must
stay on course with the current policies
to build a solid basis for Europe's
future prosperity
I'm referring in particular to the
reforms and Investments agreed by the
member states in the recovery and
resilience plans
uh hundreds of billions of Euros in
Grants will be disbursed to member
states over the next few years as I meet
the milestones and targets identified in
their plans and in the next months we
expect them to request a 225 billion
euros in loans that remain available
uh to conclude honorable members
although this has been a brief overview
I hope I outlined many initiatives and
the comprehensive approach that the
commission is applying to the current
situation thank you and I look forward
for this debate
thank you very much
our next speaker is Mr Marcus Faber the
floor is yours
Philadelphia
thank you very much vice president
Council representative
their colleagues this is not the first
time now
since the War Began in Ukraine
that we discuss the consequences that we
draw from all this we've heard a great
deal about what we wish to do but
father little has been done
so if you analyze the situation
it becomes clear you need to think about
um increasing the supply because we do
have a problem of shortages of supply
and that's something that we've been
discussing for over half a year but
nothing's been done well I know there's
a green paper from the European
commission dating back to the year 2000
when we talked about pooling our
purchasing within the European Union to
have a common approach and it's taken so
many years for us to discuss this now
the commission will be looking at its
work program for the following year if I
look at the problems we are currently
facing I simply don't find those
reflected in there there's more
bureaucracy no relief for businesses or
citizens and the priorities that are
clearly being set are being set in the
wrong way and it's not proactive it's
reactive which is a mistake thank you
the next speaker is the representative
of the Socialist and Democrat group Ms
Garcia better
gracias president thank you president
these times are difficult we know that
the cost of living crisis is coming
about because of the war we're also
seeing uh energy crises we're seeing
inflation internationally that we
haven't seen for a great deal of time in
Europe
this means that people can't pay their
bills and that's what we're discussing
here today
what we're seeing because of this is
social inequality an increase in poverty
uh particularly amongst those who are
most affected by the crisis
policies from the European Union and
National governments should be focusing
now on finding solutions to these
problems to ensure that people can pay
their bills
the European social Democrats have
concrete ideas about this about what we
can do to support businesses and
Families how we can reform the workings
of the energy market and strengthen
social well-being in a fair manner first
of all we need a solidarity package for
the winter from the European Union
this should include uh transfers in
order to offset the rising Energy prices
we can't wait any longer because we
can't let people have to choose between
heating or eating
the problems that we're seeing show that
we need to
have a permanent part of the budget
focused on crises
as we saw during the pandemic
furthermore we have to ensure that the
social security networks are strong and
effective member states have to
immediately implement the minimum wage
directive we know that the
it took her two years for member states
to transpose this regulation but at the
moment what we need is to see it working
because people need it already
we shouldn't let anyone fall out of the
electric grid and then thirdly we need
more funding in order to finance these
uh it's a question of social uh justice
and
fiscal fairness
we can't
uh ask people
to pay for this if not everyone is
paying for it equally
um we need to have an urgent
implementation of a windfall tax and
minimum taxation for multinationals not
just for companies in the energy sector
finally Europe has to
urgently put forward an in-depth reform
of energy markets
to ensure that we have more Diversified
sources of energy and that we can reduce
our dependence on Putin and fossil fuels
in general
recent years have been the most
difficult the European Union has seen
war is back at our door
and what we're seeing now is a rise in
extremism and nationalism in the
European Union what we need is
solidarity in the EU and so I ask the
commission and the council to overcome
these stumbling blocks and to bring the
solutions that our citizens want to see
[Applause]
thank you
now Mr pislaru has the floor on behalf
of the renew group your president vice
president
dear distinguished members of the
council dear colleagues we are indeed
living in difficult times and in
difficult times what we need is three
important ingredients we need ambition
we need flexibility and we need
solidarity ambition is important these
days because regardless the pain that we
are feeling all of us today we need to
be resolved and keep the important goals
that we've set at the European Union
level and that means that the Dual
transformation the green and the digital
the way we would like to get the
Strategic autonomy we should not you
know cancel our results on this on the
second time we need flexibility we need
to have creative instruments that can
reunite the resources that we put
together and then we also need in times
of difficulty a solidarity that only us
at European level can achieve together
and for that it's important to have a
view at the citizens and the
entrepreneurs and the self-employed and
renew Europe is proposing something that
you've already seen in the public sphere
a shield a shield that will not
necessarily imply that states know
everything for our citizens but that we
go close to them and allow them to have
the necessary micro Investments to do
that and they repower you it's exactly
the instrument that we've been working
together these days in the parliament
we've seen the commission we've seen the
general approach of the council and this
is something that can goes down and have
the micro Investments at the vulnerable
Hospital level at smes at micro
Enterprises level this is a way of
pushing forward with solidarity this is
the renew way this is the European way
thank you very much
foreign
thank you now Ernest another Frost
y
good morning
from Strasbourg let me express my
solidarity to all workers in France who
are
calling for fair pay
um in the wake of inflation the war in
Ukraine has only made things harder with
this inflation
um being driven up and it's having an
impact on our social Fabric and it's
going to show up the errors of the past
and of past policies and show us just
how important ecological transition is
we just have to look to the United
Kingdom to understand the situation but
this is also a time for us now to
um rescue our economies from a rise of
neo-fascism there are three parties now
we must reform our electricity market
and make it resilient to power Cuts
secondly we need to tax uh windfall uh
earnings from of companies Not Just
Energy companies um no one must be we
protect people against being evictions
this winter and we need to deal with the
cushioning the risk of variable interest
rates on mortgages and support
households as well we need to create a
new fund for ecological transition as
commissioner as gentiloni and others
have suggested and proposed now this is
no time for us to drag our feet the time
to act is now thank you
[Applause]
president commissioner's colleagues
faced with the problems following the
invasion of Ukraine we direct our
disappointment at the commission because
it failed to carry out a preventive
assessment of the social and economic
impact
from the further
impetus between behind price Rises and
the cost structure of businesses
I think that the commission has to
contemplate the solution put forward by
Keynes in his work how to pay for the
war from 1939.
eight months since the War Began we
still don't have Solutions shared
between member states European citizens
are facing the Dilemma of whether to pay
utility bills or
do their food shoppings
shopping while businesses have to decide
between paying higher energy costs and
raising prices or closing down and
firing their own Workforce
the public and private financial
situation is precarious neither have the
tools to tackle a systemic crisis from
its outset
this cannot legitimize the independent
initiatives of individual member states
which create serious asymmetries within
the single Market if the commission
allows member states to intervene
directly with their own resources
without offering their Alternatives
they'll be illicit competition in the
European Marketplace breaching articles
107 and 108 to the tfeu the most
manifest case is the 200 billion Euro
Aid plan from Germany supporting its own
system of production the time delayed
consequences of this policy will
undermine public consent in the
institutions disrupting the stability of
the European agreements specifically at
the time in which a fast-moving world is
finally examining whether they're valid
um
we need today courageous Market
interventions in order to protect
consumers from the negative impact of
high energy crisis we need for instance
to limit
wholesale prices of gas we need to
freeze ETS prices and introduce
mechanisms that would limit increases in
those prices the commission should also
help the weaker member state so that the
stronger member states do not intervene
while they have a dominating position
but their president ladies and gentlemen
we need something else we also need to
think about our entire energy and
climate strategy of the EU
in
her first speech in 2019 the president
said that the commission would be a
geopolitical one however this Commission
in it's ambitious
ecological and economic projects forgot
about the reality as if Russia did not
exist unfortunately this policy of this
commission failed no you are the one
excuse me
colleagues you will certainly have
noticed that France is on strike today
this is a social movement that is
growing just as a popular anger is
growing across Europe because the price
of pasta has gone up by 40 oil 127
butter 32 but wages are not following
people are missing meals uh having to
scrap the leisure activities and
families have to choose between filling
up their cars or turning on the heating
since uh I was little again now I'm
hearing a television report about
um at the trade unions holding French
people hostage yes it's difficult uh
people can't get on the train they can't
put their Petrol in their car children
can't go to school but who is
responsible for this is it the um
workers who are defending their rights
or is it the small number of ultra rich
people who um are doing everything to
hang on to their privilege
if you've noticed the um strike it's
because it's people who carry out
essential work that are stopping their
work imagine what it would be the case
if it was the shareholders who were on
strike nothing absolutely nothing would
change
so people who are doing useful jobs are
undergoing the full force of inflation
the less the unuseful
people who are not youthful are seeing
their profits increase
um the CEO of total has seen his um
salary in he's getting 52 percent
um more than he was
um and so what if they were to be
requisitions instead of the workers
I would congratulate the commission
finally you've finally started talking
about these super profits
and this is something that we have been
talking about and fighting for for
months however you're talking about
limiting these taxes to uh energy and
pushing it off till next year so this is
um the least you could possibly think of
you need to go further European people
want to see
um
um price caps on all of the most
essential products we saw 140 000 people
demonstrating against the rising cost of
living in Paris uh this Sunday and it's
clear that uh what we need is a rising
salaries not in shareholder profit
thank you Mr color has the full
president
honorable members
nothing has been done and nothing will
be done
sadly
this European Union that we so believed
in
just delivers nightmares poverty and
impotence
getting involved in a war that isn't
ours our people are suffering
and paying the price and the energy
crisis has not been tackled as it should
have
and
the grouped purchasing has been blocked
and now we are faced with the
consequences of a war that isn't ours
but everything that is ours that is
yours that is mine
what is it it's the suffering of people
the empty Pockets the cold the distress
and that we will face and that is this
old responsible
um for this is the European
Union
president
ladies and gentlemen it is uh
shattering where playing the old Tunes
the commissions saying it'll do
everything
uh it hasn't yet
the council
hasn't done anything yet
we've got macron energy
Olaf and so on all being discussed
macron's a problem explaining why there
are no pipelines from
Spain to France we've been talking about
the energy Revolution I think the only
solution to the problem is a common
Europe without a deepened European
energy Market none of the proposed
Solutions will be realistic in any way
every uh proposal to raise common taxes
or increasing Supply won't help we know
that we need energy terminals in one
country to have the energy in Germany
because we need a deeper energy Market
we have to acknowledge that it needs
Europe but Europe is the only way to
getting Solutions Europe is the solution
not the problem thank you thank
thank you and I'll give the floor to
Pedro Marcus
foreign
thank you president commissioner
Council
dear colleagues
trying to stop the wave of populism is
all about helping families that are
suffering smes and not able to Bear the
brunt of energy prices rising and we've
got people in France
saying they can't to take any more
they're not coping and we need a
European policy to make sure that no one
is Left Behind we need to be one market
and if we don't do this we will hand a
victory to the populace once more
so we need to do what we'd learned
during the covet crisis we solve
Europe's problems with more Europe we
did that with the covert crisis and we
need to do the same with this crisis and
future crises
let's be
consistent and fair in the way we do
that by sharing Energy across Europe
and bringing markets together and
looking at using the resources that we
have and see where those with wealth
lies in the super richest hands and also
let's not play games with those who are
suffering the most
we need to talk to the ECB and they're
talking about if further increases in
interest rates they are so disconnected
from the ordinary people who are
struggling to make ends meet we need to
say uh to the ECB they simply uh can't
increase interest rates more you know is
the Epp really on the side of Europe's
families or are they on the side of the
people who invented the idea of
austerity so let's put an end to this
excuse me
foreign
thank you president commissioner
Minister since the beginning of the
conflict European citizens have shown
their solidarity with you Ukrainian
people that's our duty that's our
responsibility and it's our honor to do
say
When Vladimir Putin is using energy and
food as a an arm a weapon in his wall
our citizens are experiencing the
economic uh fallout in an unprecedented
manner that's affecting everyone in
every sector the European Union will be
putting it in place a
windfall tax about 140 billion that will
allow governments to support those who
need it most but let's not stop at that
we need to limit gas prices we need to
ensure that we can carry out joint
purchasing the European level
commissioner colleagues European
citizens are looking to us
and now we need to be focusing on uh
moving towards a green more independent
energy sector uh one with that is more
environmentally friendly and shows more
solidarity thank you the next one is
excuse me
excuse me I have one blue card do you
accept it
do you accept the blue card
okay
from home
um
thank you president I was struck by your
intervention because finally I was going
to say you're using the word
windfall
taxation of excess profits I'm happy
because now Republic on Martian renew
are accepting that there are windfall
profits uh being made by a big business
and it should be taxed now it's not just
energy that is making windfall profits
would you apply this to all
multinationals I'm thinking
lvmh or the big Banks which are also
making excess profits in the crisis
uh
student colleague as you know
in the position that we sent to
president to find the lion before her
State of the Union speech our group
supported a tax on windfall profits uh
or as we attempted a contribution that's
how it works internally within the EU we
believe it's important to focus on those
who are profiting from situations as
they are being experienced right now
that's our priority so we want to focus
on all of the
uh companies that are profiting due to
the war particularly in the energy
sector then we'll see how we can develop
it as the context develops thank you and
so our next speaker is Madame Sarah
Matthew excuse me
in
at home again every day I see people who
can no longer pay their energy bills or
for whom transport has become too
expensive energy businesses and other
sectors are generating record profits at
the same time ladies and gentlemen that
drives people mad we
aren't all in the same boat in this
crisis
because this crisis is cynically
creating winners these big Winners
aren't supplying anything different to
in previous years they're just becoming
rich because of a war that's why we must
ensure that excess profits are
channeled back to the families so that
they can insulate their homes and uh
get solar panels but that's not enough
I think we must have these profits where
people are getting rich from nothing
we saw the same sort of thing with
Pharma profits during the covid crisis
ladies and gentlemen we need to ensure
that member states get this profit back
to the people who need it to eat and to
heat their homes
my dear colleagues
the conflict in Ukraine which is much to
be regretted is uh
um
it's going to have an impact in Europe
and we need to welcome everything that's
been said Marine Le Pen on a peace
conference
and now we hear that the Minsk
agreements could have
um avoided all these tragic events
Jackson and Sarkozy and others and Luke
have spoken out on this issue but miss
Wonderland
has
um excluded any kind of
um
pursued this armed
um
course of action and lost her vision for
Europe and and pursued the globalized
um Pro U.S vision of the world order
so it seems that there are some who
would prefer a good War to a bad piece
but there is a price to be paid and the
price will be felt by Europeans
Europeans are going to be paying footing
the bill for something that they never
caused
55 billion euros were spent on
reconstructions we expect that Europeans
will be suffering the cost of corruption
in Ukraine do you want an endless war no
we don't want a new war and we don't
want this in Europe
uh our next speaker is Mr van overtwelt
Johan
foreign
commissioner colleagues
we are back in the uh dangerous triangle
that we had been warned about before the
summer
there are three sides to this
independent independent science climate
energy and purchasing power we have
heard a lot about price caps but it
doesn't work we need solutions that will
provide security and these have to be
based on nuclear because it's a
sustainable and stable source of energy
there are some member states such as
Belgium who would like to go further
than the commission plans
uh but this is uh of course a much
higher bar when it comes to Energy
prices
Energy prices themselves are not a main
factor in deciding inflation
what we're seeing is
um a broader social unrest and this now
seems to be inevitable
in order to bring inflation under
control we need uh to tighten our belts
in monetary and budgetary terms
but we have waited too long in certain
areas and recession seems inevitable wow
foreign
thank you president
one of the key economic and social
consequences of the war has been the
return to austerity thinking
and it's not just the Epp that's
supporting this thinking we're going to
see silent rays and
um pensions being cut the biggest Cuts
we've seen in recent years and is going
to be
the biggest decline in incomes in modern
history and this is something that even
the socialist government is supporting
and it was only at the 11th Hour that an
agreement was reached on uh taxing uh
windfall profits of energy companies and
still it's going to involve certain uh
tax relief for certain Big Country
Companies and this is the same socialist
government that is in supporting the
idea of further interest rate hikes so
it's Epp thinking the same thinking
and we are seeing
problems across the board in Europe with
the same policies that were adopted in
the past coming back to haunt us now
according to Tiana
to China begin
thank you president commissioner
colleagues
high energy costs in Europe are pushing
millions of families under the poverty
line and because mine is a country of
smes it's also seriously threatening
three and a half million jobs
therefore
joint gas purchases are good we've been
calling it for years and even better is
to abandon the Amsterdam market price
index where now the majority of Market
participants are not energy companies
but speculators and lastly it's
excellent to set a gas price cap we've
been calling for it since the beginning
of the crisis and it can really help
citizens if it's properly implemented
but what will really make the difference
for businesses and for families is to
create a new energy Recovery Fund
thereby jointly raising capital in the
marketplace and transferring it to
Europeans in difficulties the measures
aimed at reducing energy bills won't
work straight away we needed them
yesterday and one alone won't work we
need them all and we need them now thank
you
thank you Mrs Pilar del Castillo
president commissioners
we know that there is a reason for the
rise in energy price bills that's why we
need decisive action from the commission
and member states which will allow
temporary measures
to ensure they can act immediately the
council and commission are talking about
whether they should
um
impose a solidarity tax on fossil fuel
companies
what's important is that measures such
as this one has to meet its objective
and that this money should go directly
to the families and businesses that need
it most furthermore
we need to be focusing on
profits not bills they're two very
different concepts we have to establish
measures which will allow us and allow
Industries
to ensure that they have tax credits and
lower contributions to cover gas prices
we have to help our industry because the
main objective of the European Union and
its government has to be to preserve
jobs thank you merci
foreign
Mr President our citizens are struggling
to pay their bills whilst greed is often
the only reason to raise prices
consumer received bills that they don't
understand we need to protect them in
their contracts with energy companies we
need to jointly purchase energy we need
to limit gas prices and separate gas
prices from electricity prices and put
an end to speculation on the energy
Market the response to the crisis is
solidarity but this doesn't mean the
citizen should again bear the burden
themselves it is time to take from those
who do have and give to those who don't
some people are profiting this crisis
the digital Giants although making huge
profits are letting workers go
pharmaceutical companies thanks to
vaccines have become richer than the
countries that use taxpayers money to
subsidize the development of these same
vaccines
the Surplus profits of energy companies
this year will be 200 billion euros This
Is War profiteering
we socialists do not simply offer ideas
in this crisis but Solutions
the windfall tax should be paid by all
those who profited greatly from this
crisis the pandemic created one
billionaire every 30 hours and almost 1
billion people were pushed into extreme
poverty only 10 richest people own more
than a third of the world population it
is time for time for everyone to pay
their fair share not just because we
need the money and we do but because it
is most of all fair thank you
okay
and bought this
thank you Mr Jordy kenyas
thank you president commissioners
it's a great shame that
while we're seeing 100 200 300 fold
increases in energy bills that our
citizens are having to pay but also smes
and businesses
and we're seeing the an equivalent
increase in business profits is that
fair no and is it acceptable that
citizens
are suffering while companies benefit
from the same situation well no it's a
time of Crisis and why should it be the
same people eat time and again paying
for every crisis is that fair no so the
people who are having windfall earnings
need to be taxed
is that fair that they they're earning
all this extra cash just because it came
their way no it's not it's the smes the
citizens that are really
um
paying the prices price
in order to benefit those who are
benefiting from the war and so we need
to really change this so that it's not
always the same people paying the bill
Smith Anderson
thank you
thank you
the recession and high energy prices are
putting many Europeans into anxiety more
and more people are anxious about the
winter is therefore good that member
states use their resources for example
to bring in a gas price cap the problem
isn't that member states are acting the
problem is that if at a European level
there's no action
with more European solidarity will get
through the winter better and that will
mean that a European gas price cap and
mandatory Energy savings are needed
straight away for all member states we
Greens in the house were the first
pleading for uh windfall tax for energy
companies we are happy that the
commission now
is bringing in the taxation of windfall
profits but this needs to be implemented
properly nationally member states
should not go for 33 percent but 50
percent taxation of wind for profits we
need to close the loopholes so that the
profits don't go to other countries
allowing a recalculation we need an
agreement with Switzerland so there's no
profit Shifting the finance ministers
need to get doing this straight away
thank you
thank you and now Mr Paulo Borgia
thank you president commissioner
the second President of the Italian
republic said that inflation is an
odious tax on the poor
and yet uh
if you look at the impact of rising
Energy prices on the lowest income uh
groups you can see the impact is having
we
have to be frank
uh even heating has become something
that only the rich can afford
foreign
there's been a war on gas for years now
and this means that our continent has
become increasingly
independent on Russia we can't wait any
further uh we need to accept a certain
amount of humility and
accept that uh you need to abandon your
ideology and move towards a different
sources of energy in Nicola you are the
next one
Mr Nicola procaccini
thank you president thank you
Commissioners energy price bills are no
longer sustainable for families and it's
the Cuda grass for
manufacturing industry which is still
left uh
flat out from the covid crisis there are
many measures that EU could have put in
place to contain energy costs
a gas price cap decoupling of energy
prices attacks on windfall profits
common purchases from third countries
but nothing has been done
thus far I remind you that
energy supplies from coal were what led
the first countries of Europe to unite
70 years ago so we the conservatives say
that the EU
should be less concerned with trifling
Little Things
and focus on the few big issues we
weren't wrong
I think we have ever less time available
to us and now we have to give
the European Union a reason to be there
otherwise it will be too late
president uh Mrs Rico
gracias president
thank you president
right now no one has any doubt as to the
fact that eating and buying clothes and
living costs have gone up and this is
all due to the market the way it's
constructed and the shortage of fossil
fuel supplies now we could keep making
big Grand statements and writing
headlines but it's in action that is
really playing to the hands of the big
utility companies and in Spain where the
utility companies are making bumper
profits of worth billions families and
households have seen the household
spending going up by 567 Euros per year
just to buy food and that's really
causes un and unease and unrest that
we're seeing reflected in protest
movements in France today and it can be
avoided it would be as simple as
changing the system uh the way it's
constructed and the way the public
sector can intervene and if we were to
change our mindset of thinking about
energy as a right rather than a market
cost us
thank you
you
say that
the rise in prices and energy costs and
so forth the only reason behind this is
the war in Ukraine but you are well
aware
who is responsible for this
all governments and the European Union
who
are continuing with their green
transition
um
the Amsterdam stock exchange and so
forth although
you discussed this uh during European
councils you all end up with the same
idea
and on the other hand you are laughing
at us when you're talking about uh
windfall tax and and so forth what's
clear is that today in France and uh
Greece on the 9th of November people
will be out in the streets to
demonstrate
uh because people are without heating or
electric thank you very much dear
colleagues uh inflation is a bit Strat
when putting together fiscal support for
the economy we should have in mind that
if it leads to fiscal expansion this
inflation will be more difficult or more
costly and the highest cost for
inflation is always paid by by the
people so that's why redirecting of
existing money and using new resources
like windfall Tex is must the second
Energy savings are still in the center
is your Energy savings and build up
quick build up of new green effective
resources is the best way how to reduce
the risk and reduce the costs
we should not forget about keeping
single Market functioning
visual terrific if most stringent or at
least coordinated stated rules are not
the best way how to promote efficiency
of the serial single market and avoid
disruptions last not least we shouldn't
forget that Putin policy is like a
leading toward Global recession if it
happens we shouldn't forget that the
highest price is paid by at least the
developed countries thank you
thank you very much
foreign
thank you chair
foreign
millions of households will be left in
darkness the
Energy bill isn't alone is also shopping
prices and transports transport costs
this is causing social inequality
there's a covid crisis
and every
30 hours there's a new billionaire so
who's suffering from a crisis the Richer
getting richer and the poorer getting
poorer
there's so much uh belief in the free
market that few politicians dare to
intervene but
there are many people struggling to keep
their head above water and who are
dependent on the state to survive what
can we do to ensure that energy Bills
remain affordable the price cap in
combination with a windfall tax is a key
but not the only step we hope that on
Friday heads of state and government
will reach an agreement
to bring the energy markets back under
control
and then more calmly we can look ahead
to the next Winter thank you
thank you is the next speaker vice
president well it's our duty to back
Becky crane against terrorist Putin
sarajima but it's also our duty to
protect and support our citizens and our
companies in this energy crisis
millions of Europeans don't know how
they will make it through this winter
steep increases in food prices
double-digit inflation
what we need is a crisis management and
we didn't need now
this house proposed Concrete Solutions
exempting staple foods from vat more
money for smes and bigger companies
decoupling electricity prices from the
prices of gas
and we know how to finance this plan
when fall tax
and this needs to be properly
implemented by all member states
winter is coming and all our talk must
now be backed with concrete actions
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you Mrs Viola
president their colleagues while Putin
is suffering military losses he's hoping
with the change of the seasons for a
victory he's really gambling on
turbine pressure is falling and uh
solidarity falling along with
temperatures obviously he we can't
influence the weather but we can have an
impact on our unity and US holding
together
businesses are struggling they're having
to uh lay off some of the people because
of the increasing costs and in the wake
of this crisis we need an exceptional
tax to help cushion the impact so that
we can support the most vulnerable in
our societies but basically we need to
become less dependent independent in
terms of our energy supplies independent
of autocrats and if we are independent
we can really protect ourselves more
effectively
so when we talk about social cohesion
and solidarity that's important uh we
I'm confident that this is a test that
we will pass as Europeans
colleagues this
energy crisis is not one that we can
overcome easily
it's the result of a conscious political
choice and it's one that could have been
predicted uh Environmental
dogmatism
is also leading to a band nuclear our
sanctions have led to war
we're trying to impoverish Russia and
bring down prices and the opposite is
happening prices are exploding and
Putin's going to get even more money to
finance his Dreadful War we're seeing
and the result of all of this is massive
inflation
purchasing power is down
economies are also falling we are
committing suicide citizens are paying a
huge price average families are paying
four times more for their energy bills
right now they're forgotten they're left
by the side of the road and what's the
European Union doing more sanctions more
weapons
European Union the European Union was
created to ensure well-being and
prosperity and yet it's war and poverty
that we're seeing now
the European Union uh doesn't know what
to do we I don't even know if we'll be
able to uh solve this
uh we are already
um
experiencing uh difficulties and this
volley has to end Alexander this word
yo ladies and gentlemen I told this over
and over again we can't fight two Wars
at once against Putin and carbon it's
above our weight
yes we must contain Putin for any price
yes we must support Ukraine yes we must
be independent of Russia's supplies
yes we are cupping the prices and
introducing the windfall tax
but it's not enough to keep social
stability and prices under control both
liberal democracies is the home and
friendly cooperation inside EU are in
danger
therefore we should slow down our
radical decarbonization effort by
mitigating the ETS system
by
allowing the LNG long-term contracts by
capping the energy prices the gas from
the electricity
and finally also by rehabilitating fully
the nuclear energy as the stable source
of Base load this is the way to cheaper
energy
um what is
thank you president honorable colleagues
Europe has gone got into a crisis
energies prices are going up smes are
fighting for survival Industries are
going bankrupt the reason is obvious the
war and the wrong sanction policy the
wrong reply to the war that is why we
cannot pay the bills today the solution
is to rethink these sanctions because
energy supplies is a matter of physical
things and not of ideology we cannot
risk the energy supplies of Europe we
cannot risk jobs in Europe we have to
pursue policies that is supported by the
people for instance the Hungarian
National consultation about sanctions is
such a policy because the ever deepening
crisis can only be tackled with the
support of the society that is why it is
unacceptable that in this situation
Brussels retain gains 600 billion euros
as a resource every member State should
be given the resources due so that it
can be channeled to the citizens as soon
as possible thank you
the floor is yours
Putin's armed forces have undeveloped
but he retains a strong grip on energy
Supply
for now
he will try to weaponize the winter to
weaken resolve and support for Ukraine
do you remember states must introduce a
range of measures and supports to help
households and businesses and protect
citizens from the worst energy price
Heights
immediate actions of the energy crisis
should not be at the detriment of the
future needs of our Energy System
yet the market should be for the benefit
of society not siphon the life from it
it is only right to apply windfall
charge to actually give that money back
to citizens
to reduce energy bills for consumers in
the longer term
the answer is clear embrace the Energy
Efficiency principle and get renovating
the built environment but for now
the windfall profits being made by
producers and above all by Traders of
the Energy System must be subjected to
storm Force taxes this astronomical
antimodal profits must be taxed as soon
as possible
foreign
foreign
thank you president many have said that
this energy crisis is threatening
millions of Europeans uh jeopardizing
their livelihoods and ordinary employees
cannot afford these price Rises it will
affect the poorest 30 percent of people
in Europe can't build up any savings so
wages up prices down and solidarity with
those who have to strike in Europe we've
already talked about financing this with
windfall profit taxes but what's really
worrying me the great concern is the
explosion in Energy prices
threatening millions of jobs in energy
intensive Industries and if we act
quicker here and don't just leave it run
then the backbone of you it won't break
but if that does happen then we'll see
impoverished regions and more dependency
less autonomy Europe must act more
quickly and cannot just assume that the
problem will resolve itself
if you want a decent Prospect for the
future you must boldly act now president
honorable members
energy and food are the basis of our
existence and it's a very fragile ground
that we're standing on people are
worried about food prices and general
cost of living and the spiraling
inflation this is a situation that Putin
is causing in order to under mine
solidarity and
um that's not something we can allow to
continue we must not just talk about it
but act uh take concerted action and
fight inflation we are
dealing for example with the situation
looking at nuclear power in Germany
we're trying to purchase power from
reliable Partners uh improve our
infrastructure and build our capacity to
generate power and make structural
changes and provide relief for Citizens
and businesses and so that uh we've got
the gas and electricity price break but
it's not something that you can just do
overnight but we are making progress and
we are staying confident staying
together and United and this is
something that's going to stand Us in
good stead against aggression from Putin
and show our solidarity with Ukraine as
well
foreign
commissioner colleagues
I welcome the opportunity that we have
to call once again for a tax on windfall
profits however the situation is
anything but
um one took that we should welcome
citizens are facing extreme prize hikes
in vital services such as uh energy and
food and yet we see uh CEOs and
shareholders in the same sectors energy
and food uh making huge profits 50
increase in totals profits in 2022
50 increase on the CEO of total's uh
salary increase in 2022.
and yet we're not seeing uh similar
taxes if you look
at our European citizens and ask
yourselves can we let this Injustice
continue
it's fair that the excess uh bonuses
made available to shareholders should be
used to help the most vulnerable this is
a social choice for our society we have
to avoid concentration of wealth which
also leads to impoverishment of the
majority and what is thank you Mr Gunner
back has the floor
thank you president
oil prices have doubled since 2021 it's
threefold increase for coal and for gas
it's been a five-fold increase and
follow
the statistics of the I uh MF we're
going to see increases all the way up to
2026 why because
the cost of CO2 certificates has uh
doubled and generally the climate
policies are responsible as well
uh it's the energy companies and the EU
itself that's benefiting from all this
and now some of the windfall taxes are
um in when for profits are going to be
taxed and that's great but who's going
to pay for it
and who's it's not consumers that will
benefit it's going to be the EU itself
in order to set yet more demanding CO2
and climate objectives they've got an
eight percent uh Target
and no region in the world not even the
United States is actually at that level
of ambitious well what I can say you're
not trying to save the world you're
trying to spread
um poverty and grief for all Europeans
thank you
thank you president
there's China is responsible for 27 of a
global emissions and yet you're talking
about how to ask uh Europeans to pay for
the sacrifices that are needed for your
globalist agenda
you know there are third Powers you're
talking about creating Renewables but
this is what has led to the huge prices
for
um these companies
we're seeing a Spanish people subject to
higher uh vat and disappearance of
middle class and these
uh if you want to really um would you
bring down um climate bills we have to
allow families um to be free to choose
um uh the energy we have to have a plan
for companies
um avoiding new taxes on new sanctions
on them we can't be hypocritical we
shouldn't be sanctioning uh European
companies we have to increase energy
production using all types of sources of
energy that we know put an end to
speculation on co2 emissions and finally
we have to ensure that members can
pay for their bills and pay for their
houses and if we can't do that then
let's just forget about it
next speaker
is
citizens have been attacked by three
sides inflation
energy Rising Energy prices and finally
the destruction of economy
in France trade unions have called for a
general strike from today last week we
were in Brussels and there are also
protests around the parliament's
building citizens Farmers all those who
are facing increasing costs winter has
only arrived in Croatia even before this
crisis household incomes were mostly
directed at paying electricity bills and
other bills prices have remained the
same and the creation Energy company is
amassing great losses and is in danger
of bankruptcy these costs can be covered
by funds and budgets however due to
recession due to a weakened economy this
Dam will not sustain the flow of water
for a long time cheap energy is the
solution if you don't want our economies
to collapse when Croatia was in in war
nobody helped us during the crisis this
type of policies needs to be ended
up
thank you our next speaker is on his way
so I give the floor to Agnes for now
at work is
thank you president
the verb is to live not to survive
but survival is a reality for ever more
people ever more people don't know at
the beginning of the month
how they will make ends meet pay the
rent buy their shopping at the end of
the month today's crisis shows the
vulnerability of our essential Services
Energy prices
uh
exposed to the power of the market and
the European plans
for an energy cap
help
they ward off the hardest blows but
these are just symptoms
and we have to cure the underlying
disease
in the European social rights uh
Charter says that we all have the right
of access to essential services like
energy water and transport and that's
what Europe has to guarantee
that is a solid foundation that people
can build their lives on thank you
now give them
politics is often a matter of unpleasant
doses this is certainly one of them
Europeans are under pressure winter is
waiting and Europe will Europe will be
hit hard should we politicians intervene
in a well-functioning market in the
attempt for emergency Solutions
on the face of it you would say no but
we cannot we cannot do that this is an
extraordinary crisis it calls for
Extraordinary Measures the essential
point now is that the solution we
produce actually ensures that the energy
Market continues to function so the
prices can regulate themselves also in
the future and so that investors want to
invest in green energy going forward
right now we have to get through the
winter and that cause for Extraordinary
Solutions thank you kill
hair cuff you want the next one
thank you very much Mr President
in an age of private yachts and super
jets as the super rich get richer it is
time for windfall taxes
five months ago this week on 19th of May
this house adopted a resolution calling
for a windfall tax on energy companies
but two weeks ago we rejected a call for
attacks on the excessive profits of
Corporations benefiting from the crisis
while we've been debating this tax for
five months households across Europe
have seen their energy costs soar
small businesses shut down and millions
are falling below the energy poverty
line we have Solutions introduce a
windfall tax differentiate between
fossil fuels and Renewables and share
the revenues with households we also
need to ban evictions and disconnections
and we need to increase the minimum wage
to a living wage the crisis is here
right now households and small
businesses are experiencing it and it's
not far off in the future so now is the
time for Action thank you
thank you
I bought this here
thank you Mr Raven is next as the music
stopped what is record
when
um with when the Music Stops uh we're
going to have problems as long as the
music plays we have to continue to dance
it was the CEO of Citigroup who said
that uh just before the financial crisis
and now once again we're on the Dance
Floor
um people are in their homes citizens
are waiting to see what music is going
to play and if it's going to continue to
play for a week a month a year
but if you look at what the commission's
saying I just keep hearing the same
thing
um be careful with how much you spend
sharing the debt more regulation more
authoritarian regulation in member
states
um more European Union
colleagues we have to be clear all of
this it's not a solution this is all
what caused these problems
we are at the dawn of an unprecedented
recession and the time has come to act
we have to
um get over our addiction to subsidies
uh music has stopped the parties over
you are the next one
thank you president
we've seen historic levels of inflation
and they're really
Breaking All the statistics and we're
seeing families that are panelists
trying to make ends meet for the basic
needs food prices Energy prices
transport costs are all driving
families to desperation
now they are exploiting all the full
resources of their salaries in order to
pay the for these basic
things
people are suffering and from energy
poverty
we don't need Grant statements we need
specific measures now we need
taxation on windfall earnings to be
decided at a European level they need to
be targeted to support families small
businesses and to keep the economy
afloat
just a final word for the national
government and specifically the
Portuguese government you cannot
limit yourself to window dressing you
need
to take political responsibility when it
comes to these issues thank you
buenos dias
good morning president commissioner
Council
prices are high
electricity and energy bills are also
very high and the European Central Bank
it continues to do what it always has
it's important for the political
authorities the commission Council and
Parliament to reach an agreement
that we can't leave inflation entirely
in the hands of the European Central
Bank
because
uh this would not be the best thing
so if it's not up to the ECB what can we
do I think that when it comes to energy
in particular there's a lot that we can
do I welcome the announcements made by
the commission but
the capacity for the EU to consolidate
the energy Market there's a lot that we
can do there and of course we need
proper financing for households and
families uh to help pay their bills the
solidarity that the commission has
proposed is good it can help to fund a
European instrument that will reduce
prices thank you
[Applause]
what
miscommissioned so it's eight months now
that this energy crisis started
eight months and I have still not seen a
coherent plan
by the European Commission
I find it hugely disappointed
at this point because it's it's your job
to come not with a fragment approach but
with a global structural approach
and there is no one you're talking about
price caps okay you're talking about
windfall talks but what is the whole
picture what will you do to tackle this
energy crisis I think you have to do
three things that is an energy purchase
platform that's completely different
what you are doing now you will you will
you will buy together 15 percent
in 2023 is the opposite what you have to
do you buy together 85 percent
where is the Security fund for the
Investments that we absolutely need and
where is the energy assistance plan for
the households or companies the same as
we did with coffee why we don't repeat
it now you are right when you criticized
in this opet uh the German approach with
the 200 billion but it's not only
necessary to criticize that you have to
also to come forward with an alternative
and we're going to do that with the
number of MEPS in a few moments we're
going to send you a letter about it with
these proposals cross-party thank you
next time
president thank you president
vice president of the commission Council
representative State colleagues
we are
now winter is approaching and many
families are asking how they will be
able to pay for their utility bills how
they will be able to cope with the cost
of living and
people have already said that valuable
time was lost but finally we have
proposals from the commission on the
table now it's late but it's better late
than never we've got the solidarity uh
Levy some a break on gas prices at
common purchasing of gas and
we've got a number of proposals on the
tail so I'd like to use my speaking time
to call upon the member states now to
roll up their sleeves and I'd call upon
the council presidency specifically to
really wrap all the member states on
their Knuckles and ensure that they do
their homework we are far from having a
common energy Market in Europe but if we
really want to get this crisis under
control we must act together which means
that we must tap into all the resources
that we have across our lands thank you
and now give the floor to Irene accident
their colleagues their commissioner for
months we've been saying to people that
the rising cost of energy was something
limited and temporary but it's not been
like that and let's face it it will not
be like this in the future governments
had to intervene massively to support
families and businesses and we'll have
to do that again in the future but it's
not going to be sustainable in the long
term we know that so what does it mean
it means that this will affect the
competitiveness of our businesses will
affect the single market and bring about
fragmentation so and we'll also have a
spillovers that will aggravate and
accelerate a possible recession all over
the European Union so we need to
intervene very quickly urgently onto
fronts one provide a genuine European
instrument to provide support to those
countries that don't have the fiscal
space to and also to restore the single
market and then we need an incisive
intervention on the energy Market yes
the joint procurement but we need
something more more ambitious on the gas
price on the coupling gas from Energy
prices if you are not ambitious now we
will regret when it will be too late
thank you Cuts here
[Applause]
thank you Mr President your commissioner
Minister colleagues let me be as usual
very straightforward I'm deeply
concerned by the ease and speed with
which the council including my own
government approved the so-called with
vote tax
I'm concerned because wind for tax does
not necessarily reduce bills which is
the theme of our debate but rather
subsidizes the most unsustainable of all
forms of electric generation these from
natural gas
distorts Natural Market incentives and
eventually geopardizes the business
plans and Investments of more
sustainable and viable alternatives
and I am extremely concerned by the
population with which this house
discusses extension of so-called
windfall tax on other businesses
it is market-based innovation and
competition that could lead us out of
this crisis and not breaking the free
market thank you
don't care
thank you
thank you president commissioner
every uh winter we have tens of millions
of Europeans who don't know how they're
going to pay the bills in Winter and
don't know whether they're going to have
the food to the money to buy food or
medicines and now inflation has driven
us into an impossible situation for them
uh where
flower
sugar and other Staples have become
unaffordable
and there's a lack of action from the
commission which hasn't acted for many
days we've seen inflation as a result
in Energy prices we've seen 80 percent
inflation and now you've got the issue
of costs
at the same time companies are making
excess profit
and the excess profits are leading to
inflation
all the energy companies
uh making windfall profits for years
they've been left to do that and we're
all paying the price now
so let's uh responsibly tax windfall
profits and then we'll be able to get
through this winter thank you
thank you Miss Bank Commission
faced with the Dreadful energy inflation
crisis
uh problems with uh paying mortgages due
to interest rates
we already have a tool to try to tackle
this these are the Next Generation funds
that the commissioner is very familiar
with we're talking about 800 billion
euros
and a large amount of this is still
waiting to be invested
and I'd like to take this opportunity to
urge the commission
to do everything it can to ensure that
this 800 billion euros is implemented in
an effective and Rapid manner so that
they can work for the real economy for
families and businesses
and also
you ensure that member states carry out
the reforms that are necessary to
accompany this uh These funds
to ensure that we can make our economy
more competitive and that this liquidity
that is so necessary can go into the
economy so use the Next Generation funds
commissioner and call upon the
commission to do its work to ensure that
this money is spent quickly thank you
foreign
thank you very much
Mr
compula populos as the floor
Michael
yes
thank you president commissioner
honorable members
the Russian invasion of Ukraine
has been
going on for more than eight months now
and it's having an impact on the
sovereignty of that state and with a
knock-on effect for Europe and the rest
of the world
of a great magnitude we're trying to
take measures now to guarantee security
for everyone
but there are clearly disruptions to the
supply chain within the internal Market
the energy crisis will once again hit
citizens across Europe and many
businesses at the same time however are
making bumper profits as on the back of
this situation so in Greece we're
talking about taxing
um Surplus profits
for the duration of this crisis
the problems are clear and plain to see
across the European Union these measures
need to be adopted because the burden
for households and citizens are
increasing all the time
thank you we moved to the catch to the
eye round and I give Maria Walsh the
floor first
thank you
I should not speaking oh my God there's
no microphone there's an 8749
Madame Walsh can you please turn on the
micro
it's not working
isn't it oh there we go thank you very
much
um I welcome the reactive measures such
as the proposed introduction to a
windfall tax but it should not have
taken European leaders over 236 days of
a crippling crisis to introduce such
measures while this debate focused
primarily on using the windfall attack
mechanism on fossil fuel companies we
must utilize this instrument for the
large building suppliers and
supermarkets ensuring families feeding
their families and building their homes
and growing their businesses can survive
the coming weeks and months in addition
it is incredibly important we recognize
the cost of living crisis is affecting
people's mental well-being following
this debate we will lead a dedicated
discussion on Mental Health these two
discussions are connected now more than
ever this emphasis the need for
comprehensive EU approach to mental
health and not just talked about in
times of Crisis but a Cornerstone for
all 27 member states thank you very much
thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman
Mr commissioner I agree with the
colleagues that
currently in this situation we need
to address the windfall and have a
windfall tax we need to cap the gas
prices especially as as much as that
relates to generation of electricity we
also need a
good distribution of the wind windfall
towards small businesses and families
but there's another thing
we need to carry on with our commission
commitments I'm sorry
Mr damask is over the left
the room but I wanted to say that
farmers in Poland and Lithuania are
still getting smaller payments than
compared to other countries and that's a
shame
I urge the commission to follow through
with their commission commitments we
have to be we have to work with
solidarity because that's the only way
how we can deal with Putin with the
energy blackmail and stop populism in
Europe thank you very much
thank you
Mr kirtas next
thank you president here
we are speaking in great detail and a
great length but
in my opinion
we know what the impact on the economy
will be and on citizens if we want to
change something we need to change the
way in which the electricity Market
operates because we know that is our
weak spot when it comes to Putin
the wholesale price for electricity
generation needs to be disconnected from
natural gas and as has already been said
the taxation of windfall profits needs
to happen as quickly as possible and my
fourth Point perhaps even more important
is that we have to stop giving money to
Putin in August
1.8 billion euros were transferred to
for Russian gas by Greece three times
the 2021 figure it's impossible for us
to financially support such an
aggressive policy lastly I believe it is
discernible that
in our
strategically important sectors like
energy Europe hasn't been present enough
Wallace very much president
it makes sense to ties to win proud
profits of energy companies but the rate
proposed 33 is way too low if the tax is
calculated only on excess profits
the the race should be at least double
that and in some cases a hundred percent
this should not be a one-off tax we need
a permanent windfall tax mechanism one
that applies to all sectors it should
apply to any company that makes XX
profits after problems of others
we need a windfall tax on the profits of
weapons manufacturers just look at the
profits and share prices of the EU arms
industry of layers Ryan metal Tales
Airbus Leonardo
and long before the war in Ukraine these
companies were making a Fortune of the
misery of the people in Yemen by
supplying arms to the Saudi UAE
Coalition that committing a genocide
there the worst humanitarian crisis on
the planet at the moment why do we allow
these companies to make crazy profits
after misery of others
thank you very much
Maria grappini next please
thank you president commissioner we are
now discussing how to stop bills rising
and the social and economic crisis of
that but as we discuss in many member
states uh bills are being regularized
and bills are going up tenfold for
energy not just in my country
you know where energy costs have gone up
a tenfold for electricity the same in
Belgium there's a similar debate
and citizens have written saying that
their bill
has gone up something like 40 percent a
month
and what are the specific measures here
to deal with that
you know in cold regions so how are they
going to make it through
and as a vice president of the SME
Intergroup I've got a specific question
about uh
the companies in Germany Austria and
Slovakia how are we going to bring bills
down for energy
both for Citizens and for smes how are
we going to avoid the social and
economic crisis if we can't do anything
thank you yeah
thank you
again normal times this is not a free
market this is a market that's been held
to Ransom by Putin so we do need to have
Extraordinary Measures put in place I
very much welcome the proposals around
the windfall tax we do need to show in
solidarity with citizens with small
businesses with families that simply are
unable to afford electricity bills and
other gas utility bills in the weeks and
months ahead member states have gone to
extraordinary levels in some countries
to try and buffer the impact that
inflation is having on people but the
European Union must do more in terms of
bringing forward a windfall tax a
solidarity tax that can be dispersed to
people and entities and businesses that
most needed we also need to be brave in
the area of decoupling of the wholesale
electricity price from gas prices we
can't have a situation where we are
continually blackmailed held to Ransom
by Putin and his cronies in the efforts
to keep the lights on businesses going
and Farm is warm this winter we do need
to be brave we do need to change how we
price electricity in Europe
thank you
Martin Holly sickness
.com
we
need
to think about fossil fuels and gas and
how they're making us dependent and at
the same time destroying the climate and
giving handing money to Putin and
playing to the hands of Putin rather and
we need to act together to try and deal
with this problem of dependence the
European commission must be bolder in
its action and provide more support to
households and businesses across Europe
windfall taxes can't be kept at the
national level
because
this is a type of market and business
that works at the European level the
businesses have to purchase uh their
power and electricity somewhere in one
place and sell it elsewhere so we need
to be able to act across
Europe and have concerted action on the
council and commission side
thank you and now on behalf of the
commissioner of the commission sorry
commissioner Paolo gentiloni go ahead
please
uh thank you thank you chair
honorable members
let me start uh
reiterating our support
to the Ukrainian resistance I don't
think that this is a formal only
statement
because we also have to refuse the
narrative that supporting Ukraine
means not be able to support our
citizens
we will not sacrifice freedom to the
economy
Putin will not divide us
he will not Prevail if we act together
with ambition
of course we know that we are living a
multiple crisis a geopolitical energy
inflation
crisis
with an impact on the real economy
and with some risks of financial
spillovers
and This Global external shock
is asymmetric
for the consequences
first of all for low-income countries
that are
with huge huge problems of debts and
food insecurity
but also among Advanced countries the EU
is the most affected by large
and we have risks on our competitiveness
and risks of fragmentation
and social risks of course
that we are discussing today
so we will assess the evolution of this
crisis I will present in November the
11th our economic forecast
but for sure
economy is lowing down
and this multiple crisis has to be
addressed as you know the commission
will adopt later today a new package on
energy
I have to say it is a huge package
gradually we are finding common ways
among member states
of course it will not be the last
I have three key words in for the coming
weeks and months on my side
and the commission side first keyword is
coordination because of course
all the national measures are facing uh
the the social consequences of this
crisis we know that the European family
uh is spending 20 percent of the income
for food and 15 percent of the income on
energy
so 35 percent
that this is an average of course we
have several countries and several
low-income households where food and
energy are near to 50 percent of the
family expenditure and the increase that
we are looking is putting these families
these households in a very dangerous
situation and the same is happening for
a specially small and medium count
companies so we need to react to support
but to avoid that this support is
undermining the monetary policy effort
because the reduction of inflation is on
the in the common interest
and it is especially in the common
interest of most more vulnerable
households
so it's an interplay not easy
because we need of course a monetary
policy we don't need exactly the same
monetary policy in all areas of the
world because Europe has particular
routes of its own inflation and needs
particular reaction but this is for the
ECB to decide and our fiscal
coordination should complete the
monetary policy and not compete with it
my second key word is solidarity
from the social point of view many
things were raised in this discussion
and I think that our solidarity
contribution on windfall profits is a a
first step
it is connected to energy for the legal
reasons that you know very well but this
doesn't mean that member states could
not go further to address these issues
solidarity means also
look to the risks of fragmentation
and we have the same concern that we had
during the pandemic
because of course we have different
physical space in different countries
and we should discuss the possibility to
look to further possible common
Financial tools based on loans to
address these risks of fragmentation and
finally competitiveness
because the risk that there is in this
asymmetric consequences of this crisis
is for Europe to lose competitiveness
and so our two main commitments first on
the clean energy transition and second
on implementing reforms and Investments
of Next Generation EU are not only
important because we have to implement
what we decide but they are important if
we want to avoid a
difficult situation for the Union in
terms of global competitiveness thank
you
foreign
thank you commissioner and now to
conclude on behalf of the council
the deputy prior Minister Ivan Bartos
has the floor for members Mr
commissioner thank you very much for
this very timely debate on such a
crucial topic the cohesion of our
societies is at stake at the end of the
day there will be a price to pay for all
of us as a result to Russia's actions
let us make sure that the burden is
fairly distributed I completely agree
with Ms Garcia Perez who echoed the
recent resolution of this house
that citizens should not be obliged to
choose between healing and eating
and I also take good note of what many
of you have said uh that everyone should
contribute in a situation of Crisis
especially those with higher profits let
me underline once again member states
and EU are doing their utmost to
question the blow on our companies and
citizens we are closely following the
evolution
uh we are closely following the
evolution of the situation and will
adapt our policies according to the
needs this is not an easy task and it
requires a swift action across several
policies and continuous articulation
between member states and EU
institutions
in time like this we should not forget
that the coordination between member
states is absolutely key to ensure the
Integrity of a single market and make
them a Level Playing Field between our
economies as Mr niedemeyer said finally
we look forward to receiving a new
proposal which the commission is going
to present this afternoon let me assure
you that the council will discuss them
swiftly so they can be have a positive
impact already this winter thank you
very much once again for your attention
and this debate
foreign
thank you very much
that concludes this debate
the next point on today's agenda is a
council and commission statement on
Mental Health
I'll start by giving the flow to
Deputy Prime Minister Ivan Bartos on
behalf of the council